un bambino bellissimo video in cui
andremo a costruire un parco acquatico
con i gonfiabili per il nostro cagnolino
berlino abbiamo comprato un sacco di
gonfiabili per costruire il nostro super
parco acquatico per il nostro cane anche
una super piscina e piscinetta è un
tappetino un'anguria è un giochino
vediamo l'ora di vedere come sarà questo
nostro parco acquatico avevano
un'avventura incredibile oggi come oggi
non berlino provate a indovinare nei
commenti che reazione avrà merlino
secondo me marino proverà a mangiare
tutti i giochi gonfiabili e a
distruggerli
oppure si addormenterà sicuramente si
addormentava ora andiamo subito a
montare tutti ammontare a gonfiare e
tutti i nostri giochi gonfiabili per
creare il nostro parco acquatico quando
la domanda fi dimmi chi li compra tutti
i gonfiabili
tu sei lì compiere tutti non sono mica
un compressore e lo zoom video
gonfiatore
non mi piace entro 5
ecco qua il nostro parco acquatico per
merlino e anche un po per noi è pronto
abbiamo innanzi tutto qua dopo il re
fissi nell'anguria gigante guardate
quante più grande di questa è la piscina
gigante e poi abbiamo un'altra
piscinetta che più per merlino
come potete vedere ci sono gli spruzzi
d'acqua ovunque in questa finestra ci
sono anche delle palline traghetto uno
scivolo insomma dei giochini ferrovia
abbiamo un sacchettino
e qua un giochino con le palline
ora facciamo uscire merlino e vediamo
come reagisce
sono fermi tutti
meno bene la cosa più interessante per
berlino finora e la cuesta eccolo eccolo
soffrire dura altro pallino
berlino pensa che sia una ciotola
gigante che invece di tacco berline un
po confuso
questo lo prende le palline bene a
berlino fa il centro quasi mai il
canestro berlino questa domenica
[Musica]
[Applauso]
se vi sia piaciuto
[Risate]
la vita
sono sì perché si mangia berlino non è
una vera guida da mangiare berlino no
[Musica]
il mio giardino
berlino dopo aver sgranocchiato tutta
l'anguria finta è tornato nella
piscinetta dare l'acqua ea prendere le
palline alla palma di torino merlino
giochiamo a questo gioco di ritirare
dalle palline qua e vediamo quanti punti
fai bene qua qua lascia lascia bravo
allora un po macellati nel diritto
[Applauso]
berlino sta cercando di prendere tutte
le palline e distruggerle
abbiamo capito che sarà tutte le cose la
profonda nella piscinetta merlino
interessato solo alle palline e
all'anguria berlino ma c'è una piscina
gigante da dietro i segni del figlio
berlino con questo parco giochi
acquatico t1 bagnato berlino distrutto
quanto tutto abbiamo capito che la sua
cosa preferita da fare era bere dalla
piscinetta come se fosse la sua ciotola
dell'acqua mangiare le palline
distruggere l'anguria stupore nei
commenti se voi avete cani o gatti come
avrebbero reagito un parco acquatico con
i gonfiabili fatecelo sapere nei
commenti
mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
per altri video super divertenti ad essi
per miss trizio avevamo ancora non mi
seguite il nome anita stories se volete
ha seguiti mi anche su tito che ora vi
lasciamo 447 linee su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che fa fede
[Musica]